is that right you were so poor that you
actually sold your dog I did sold my dog
at a 7-Eleven it was either that or eat
him I
mean even when I was totally broke I
always wanted to have an animal with me
and I mean literally I was emotionally
spiritually physically bankrupt and so I
had $106 the rent was 300 I had a
pregnant wife I have a very huge British
dog as matter of fact a bull mastiff B
hey Buck give me a kiss so finally I get
the job I go back to the fellow I sold
it two he's a short guy really short so
he paid me like 60 bucks in the dog he
goes I I'll give you the dog back for
$3,000 I don't have $3,000 he goes all
right I want to be in the movie so I put
him in the movie in rocket yeah he's
he's first kind little scene I'm walk in
he goes how'd you do last night I said I
did great you should have been there he
goes don't you think you ought to take a
rest no my back is it you're back you're
DEA I'm sure